typically around five o'clock we get up
I do a black coffee I'll go down I'll
have eaas and elkana team the oral
L-Carnitine are injected oral liquid
form 15 minutes after that I'll go and
do an hour faster cardio so 30 minute
cross trainer 30 minute incline walk
let's have a 30 minute call work or 30
minute to stretch Mobility work after
that hour and then it's 30 minutes uh
posing and what time is it now so that
is seven o'clock ish wow okay so it's a
very regimented morning yeah yeah okay
so then half seven I'll go in I'll have
massive breakfast most people it's
massive but for me it's it's nothing
what does that typically consist of so
we've got a good source of protein
bioavailable protein we've got like a
whey protein or whey isolate we've got
complex carbs so oatmeal we've got
essential fats through almond butter or
almond flakes we've got blueberries
antioxidants I'll take my Multiverse CLA
Amigas all that kind of stuff we're now
at what 8 30. eight o'clock and then
obviously my son he has his breakfast
with me so I make his breakfast at the
same time I've changed his nappy twice
by then